us president biden is set to meet with
the congressional hispanic caucus today
as members of his own party are accusing
him of catering to activists and
ignoring his own border patrol that
blowback comes as republicans accuse the
department of homeland security
secretary of endangering american
citizens by failing to secure our
southern border or even trying uh david
spunt uh spont joins us now live from
washington with more hey david hi good
morning to you three it's not on his
public schedule but the president is
expected to meet privately with the
congressional hispanic caucus
at some point today sitting in on a
meeting and expect him to get an earful
from some of these democrats in that
caucus specifically not only what some
of these policies of this white house
are doing to migrants but also americans
not only living in border states but
americans all across the country it's a
trickle-down effect there's a concern
among some democrats that the party is
in trouble in november meaning the
democratic party one of the reasons is
because of this administration's border
policy specifically the inability to get
a real grip on the surge of illegal
immigration that is happening daily
right now title 42 the policy that
expels illegal migrants from the united
states citing coveted concerns will end
may 23rd that's less than a month away
that means there's expected to be this
massive surge at the border that we've
been covering several democrats have
come out publicly to warn of the surge
that will come as a result of the end of
title 42 pro-immigration activists have
urged the white house
to
keep
to end title 42 excuse me
yes they're listening to the immigration
activists but my question is who's
listening to the men and women in green
and in blue and more importantly who's
listening to the border community
and some sad news we've been following
over the weekend 22 year old bishop
evans a texas national guard soldier
went missing after reportedly trying to
rescue two migrants who appeared to be
drowning while crossing the rio grande
river from mexico a delegation of
republican members of congress will head
to eagle pass texas not far from where
he went missing later today back to you
it was pretty amazing when when they had
that what they thought was a
controversial move by those border
patrol agents on horses the president
ran to the microphone the vice president
of the microphone we're going to
investigate this but has there been any
acknowledgement by the president that
this border patrol agent uh is assumed
drowned
not publicly yet um today he's going to
be meeting on the south lawn with the
tampa bay lightning that's the only
public event that he has today again the
meeting with the congressional hispanic
caucus not public but no we've not heard
from him yet at least on camera right
and it's not going to be public because
you know that's probably going to be a
tough conversation they're going to have
with the president but david ultimately
the president's party wants to win in
november so it sounds like if you look
at the public opinion polls he really
needs an off-ramp he needs an excuse he
needs a way to say you know what we're
going to go ahead and extend it
indefinitely or whatever not just pull
the plug on may 23rd
what is the off-ramp at this point
you know it's a good question and
several democrats may have the answer
others may not i mean you're seeing
people like henry cuellar and other
members that are starting to speak out
more quail is one that we've been on for
for a while he's been speaking about it
for you know really since the president
took over back in january 2021 but as
far as an off-ramp is concerned title 42
is a major turning point uh and
apparently at this point it's not too
late for him to
um continue title
may 23rd
it expires but it could continue yeah
it's okay for the kids to wear masks up
in new york the toddlers uh because of
coveted reasons but we're gonna end
title 42 because down at the border i
guess the cove is not as big of a deal
well if you come from france thanks
david if you come from france don't you
need your nose swabbed yeah right but if
you come don't you need to show a
passport to get back in the country i
thought so uh but so it's a little bit
different but the other thing uh i i
just fear that the president's gonna act
like he i think he'll extend it probably
to july but it's going to act like well
i address but i address he's going to
say i address the
uh the border issue by it may be
extending title 42. and yet he titled
with title 42 in place they're still not
enforcing it the way they should they're
still not enforcing the remain in mexico
like a judge told them to so now you
have the governor of texas has to cut
separate deals with mayors in mexico in
order to stop the influx of all of
central and south america so it is i
don't even even when the president if
the president gives in here he's not
giving in to conservatives he's still
blown open the border and has shown no
interest in controlling it it has to be
intentional well kamala harris doesn't
go to the border though our own
president hasn't mentioned this 22 year
old bishop evans the the
border patrol agent who was down there
and trying to rescue two migrants in the
water turns out they were trying to
traffic in drugs and he goes missing
they said that they think he might have
drowned they notified his family on
friday he's from arlington texas that's
right he's in the texas national guard
he was a specialist a field artilleryman
from arlington as you said he served the
guard of two years he was deployed to
kuwait he had assignments in iraq as
part of operation spartan shield before
serving the texas border and he was
assigned to what is being referred to as
operation lone star that is governor
abbott's effort to try to beef up things
on our southern border but nonetheless
he is presumed dead at this hour went
missing trying to save
either one or two migrants who appeared
to be drowning here's the thing
now the texas department of safety has
said that those migrants apparently were
involved in illicit transnational
narcotics trafficking so he saved his
life
he's tried to save the lives of two
people who were bringing drugs into our
country and that is a terrible story and
when you look at the network news
coverage let's go ahead and put it up
how much between friday morning and
sunday at 12 30 p.m did the networks
cover it
nobody covered it except abc for 20
seconds do you think they did the part
about how he lost his life presumably
trying to save somebody who was
smuggling drugs in i bet they couldn't
work that in to those 20 seconds
congressman henry cuer are facing
headwinds for re-election down there
he's on the border and he said who's
listening to the border communities that
is my question none he also said we
should drill
so he's getting on the nerves of
democrats it should be interesting
conversation out of the 42 that show up
at the white house today for the
hispanic august i wonder how many are
going to push the president to keep it
in place and how many are just going to
stick with the party line it sounds like
two for sure
but
that leaves 40. it two versus 40. right